Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brit Love. Und hier ist es wieder
ein neues Corona Wikly nicht ganz so Wickly ähm wie es hätte sein können, aber es musste einfach mal wieder ein bisschen auch nebenbei was anderes getan werden. So oder so, sind wir aber hier in der bekannten Besetzung und ich sage hallo zum Pavillon.
Ja, Pavill hast du die Zeit für irgendwas nutzen können?
Äh ja, ich meine auch äh bei mir kehrt so langsam so ein bisschen Arbeitsnormalität ein
aber ähm ja, ich habe halt schon natürlich die Situation im Blick,
behalten und in der letzten Woche hatte sich ja da einiges zusammengebraut, vor allen Dingen in Berlin, was doch sehr beunruhigend war,
äh was äh sich aber zum Glück nicht fortgesetzt hat, äh als Trend, aber das war halt schon ein bisschen, ja, beunruhigend, äh sagen wir mal so, was in den letzten zwei Wochen so los.
Nicht nur in Berlin, sondern vor allem natürlich auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen, diese ganze äh Tunnis Fleischindustrie, äh Situation ist ja enorm in den Fokus gekommen und das äh
hat dem Herrn jetzt ja zumindest schon mal seinen Aufsichtsratsposten. Schalke null vier gekostet.
Ist das schon mal was?
Gut, es war ja nicht nur Turnies oder mehrere Landkreise, äh jetzt äh
mit Maßnahmen wieder äh zu überziehen, beziehungsweise Kontaktbeschränkungen äh dort anzuordnen und Schulen und äh Kitas äh zu schließen und all das, also das äh ja
die Folgen waren natürlich dramatisch und in Berlin hatten wir ja auch einen unglaublichen Spike
da haben sich die Fälle auch gegenüber dem Tiefststand verdreifacht und so vor einer Woche sah das aus, äh wie eine, ja, exponentielle.
Kurve wie äh als ob die zweite Welle äh jetzt losgehen würde. Aber ich hab da gesagt
ähm auf äh Twitter gut, das sieht alles sehr, sehr unschön aus und wenn das jetzt noch eine Woche so weitergeht, dann werden wir hier auch äh ganz schnell Maßnahmen brauchen. Und äh das,
ähm hat sich jetzt zum Glück nicht bestätigt, sondern ähm die Zahlen gehen wieder zurück,
So, aber es ist halt auch noch zu früh jetzt für äh eine wirkliche Entwarnung oder zu sagen
die Ämter haben's jetzt doch unter Kontrolle, was ich, was ich hoffe, aber das Ding ist ja, dass auch die ganzen Cluster, die da jetzt hochgekommen sind, es war ja nicht so
dass das innerhalb von wenigen Tagen sich so verbreitet hat und sich so viele Leute angesteckt hat, sondern dass.
Die meisten Cluster haben ja erstmal so unbemerkt vor sich hin äh sich,
entwickelt und und verbreitet und das können wir halt auch leider noch nicht,
Nach einer Woche völlig ausschließen, ähm dass sich das jetzt wiederholt und man muss halt auch sagen.
Die Zahlen waren schon mal besser. So, also wir sind noch nicht wieder da, wo wir schon mal vor drei oder vier Wochen äh waren.
Also diesen Tiefpunkt an Neuinfektionen äh haben wir noch nicht erreicht. So, aber.
Das war der, was war denn der Tiefpunkt.
Na ja kommt jetzt drauf an, ob du jetzt Berlin meinst oder im Bund, also.
In Berlin was jetzt den.
Sieben Tage Mittelwert angeht an Neuinfektionen, lagen wir schon mal so bei
ja äh fünfundzwanzig pro Tag als Mittelwert, das war so der Tiefpunkt und jetzt liegen mir so knapp unter fünfzig, also vierundvierzig im Moment für
Berlin. So,
und der Höchststand vor ziemlich genau einer Woche war fünfundsiebzig, das heißt mir haben sich halt innerhalb von vier Wochen verdreifacht, also die neue Infektion,
und ja, sind jetzt wieder um eine drittel runtergegangen, aber eben immer noch doppelt so hoch, wie wir mal waren, insofern werde ich erst froh locken
wenn wir einen neuen Durchschnitt erreichen, der unter dem tiefsten Stand liegt, den wir schon mal hatten.
Trotzdem, wenn man sich jetzt mal die Fälle je hunderttausend Einwohner anschaut, ist es ja insgesamt,
recht entspannt in Deutschland, also der höchste Stand und bezieht sich jetzt auf die letzten sieben Tage, ne? Also die Summe, der Feller, der neuen Fälle,
je hunderttausend Einwohner, das muss man ja dann immer noch berücksichtigen und das ist dieser Wert, wo wir diese magische fünfzig Mal so als Reaktions äh schwellwert
in der Diskussion hatten und auch natürlich immer noch haben und da ist Nordrhein-Westfalen jetzt gerade, als wir hier auf.
Wenn wir hier aufnehmen, nämlich am dreißigsten Juni zwanzig zwanzig habe ich noch gar nicht gesagt, liegt Nordrhein-Westfalen bei null Komma drei,
Berlin war acht Komma zwei, Deutschland insgesamt bei vier Komma null und alle anderen Länder äh dadrunter, also auch so.
Bayern und so weiter. Das hat sich alles ein bisschen.
Beruhigt. Kann man schon sagen, ne? Und gibt so Länder wie ja Sachsen-Anhalt, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, wo einfach nach wie vor ja, quasi nichts los ist oder so.
Eins oder niedriger.
Ja, wenig los, aber wir haben ja.
Leider äh kein wirklich choronerfreies äh Bundesland. Wir haben allerdings eine ganze Menge Landkreise auch äh nach wie vor und es ähm.
Wo halt wenig los ist und da hat insgesamt die Zahlen ja scheinen ähm so händelbar äh zu sein, aber das Wichtigste ist, dass sich halt der Trend nicht fortgesetzt hat, der sich in den letzten Wochen.
Letzten drei, vier Wochen so angedeutet hat mit zunehmenden Zahlen und ja, wenn das noch ein, zwei Wochen weitergegangen wär, dann.
Sehr die Situation ganz, ganz anders aus. So, jetzt besteht wieder Hoffnung.
Was natürlich Berlin äh helfen dürfte, ist, dass einfach die.
Ferienzeit angefangen hat, seit einer Woche haben also die Schulen auch richtig zu, also eigentlich die Faktor schon
locker seid, seit zehn Tagen, da ist ja dann äh auf den letzten Metern immer relativ wenig los und es war ja eher runtergefahren, das Programm, dasselbe gilt für Brandenburg, Hamburg.
Und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hat auch schon äh.
Sogar noch ein bisschen länger, paar Tage länger schon die Sommerferien, Nordrhein-Westfalen, fangen sie jetzt gerade an und Schleswig-Holstein auch. Also das dürfte sicherlich,
auch nochmal zumindest diesen Faktor Schule rausnehmen. Jetzt natürlich die Frage, was passiert durch den Faktor Urlaub, der sicherlich von vielen innerhalb Deutschlands abgefeiert werden dürfte.
Das äh ist in der Tat jetzt spannend zu beobachten, weil man sieht's halt auch an den Parkplätzen
in Berlin draußen vor der Tür, da sind wieder freie Parkplätze, das heißt
dass da schon Leute, also Berliner auch in Signifikanter Zahl irgendwo in anderen Bundesländern jetzt weilen und ja.
Das könnte sich natürlich auch ähm auf die äh Zahlen dann jetzt plötzlich in anderen,
Ländern auswirken oder auch nicht, man wird äh sehen, aber
ich hörte sowas äh von des, also neunzig Prozent der Leute, die jetzt im Urlaub machen oder planen, äh diesen Urlaub in Deutschland äh machen.
Und.
Bin äh jetzt auch gestern zufällig an der äh an einem Reisebüro, sowas gibt's sogar tatsächlich auch noch, das war zwar geschlossen hatte, aber im Schaufenster ein paar wirklich.
Ja interessante Reiseangebote wie zum Beispiel mit dem eigenen PKW durch Bayern.
Ganz neue Idee.
Also.
Das das wäre vor dem vorne vor einem Jahr wäre das noch äh so dass das Kombi-Flugticket durch aus Asien gewesen.
Ja. Ja, definitiv. Und von den, also von den sechs Urlaubsangeboten, die sie da hatten, äh waren halt vier, für.
Äh Urlaub in Deutschland. Was gibt's da noch? Genau. Bayernreise auf dem romantischen Straße im eigenen PKW. Äh.
NRW-Standortreise durchs Bergische Land per Auto, Rat und zu Fuß. So.
Ja oder Unesco-Weltkulturerbe im Osten Deutschlands. So.
Ja
Sie verlassen der Ort und sehen sie niemanden dabei.
Oder äh Radwandern an der Ostsee von Lübeck bis Stralsund. Also, ja, die Reiseindustrie scheint sich äh dort äh zumindest ja auch auf die Situation ein bisschen eingestellt zu haben gerade.
Aber ja, wir werden sehen, äh wie sich das Ganze auswirkt, also.
Positive Auswirkungen durfte es vielleicht auf das RKI geben, die ein wenig ein überforderten Eindruck machen, gab's auch einen interessanten,
äh Artikel beim NDR äh dazu, das einfach sicher in dieser ganzen Informationspolitik wenig geändert hat und man muss sich ja schon so ein bisschen fragen, dass die äh nach Monaten,
nachdem sie eigentlich im Zentrum standen, ja, immer noch mit Ausreden kommen, sie hätten ja nicht genug Personal, um die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu machen. Also, das äh,
finde ich doch nach wie vor etwas etwas verwirrend und es hat sich ja auch an diesen ganzen Datensituationen nicht wirklich irgendwas getan, ne? Und hast du da noch.
Änderung gesehen. Also nach wie vor zu wenig Informationen, weniger als eigentlich vorhanden sein müssten und was sie noch ein bisschen schlimmer finde, auch einfach überhaupt keine Debatte dadrüber, ne? Man sagt halt einfach nichts dazu
redet sich raus, man hätte ja nur keine Zeit, auf irgendwas zu antworten. Also, das finde ich, naja,
also nach wie vor unangemessen oder zu sehr draufhauen zu wollen.
Ja. Ich meine, es gibt halt die täglichen Situationsberichte, die durchaus.
Aufschlussreich sind, nach wie vor und äh ja, aber,
bei den Tests, also wir wissen immer noch nicht, äh wie viel Tests wo gemacht werden, was natürlich auch immer alle Aussagen ganz, ganz schwierig werden lässt, zum Beispiel.
Ähm so Düsseldorf,
ähm war halt so ein Ding, weil ich Düsseldorf halt auch einige Leute persönlich kenne und mich das interessiert hat, wo denn jetzt das Problem eigentlich in Düsseldorf liegt, weil da war jetzt.
Eigentlich ja kein kein Fleischverarbeitender Betrieb und.
Äh da scheint's aber eine Mischung äh zu.
Sein, so aus ganz vielen ja vielen Altersheimen und Obdachlosenheimen und Flüchtlingsheimen, die scheinen alle etwas stärker zu betroffen zu sein.
Schulen.
Äh waren halt auch einige betroffen und dann äh wurde halt viel Party gemacht in in Düsseldorf, dass,
ähm wollen dann auch in den Medien diskutiert, dass man das versucht dann irgendwie einzudämmen und der Verdacht war, dass auch Partygänger oder feiernde,
ein Problem waren, aber das hat wohl überwiegend draußen stattgefunden und dem scheint nicht so zu sein.
In Hagen,
äh wird so ein Zuckerfest Cluster dafür verantwortlich gemacht, wo es ja auch in Berlin so den Verdacht gab, dass einige der Zahlen darauf zurückzuführen
sind, aber das wollte halt auch nie offiziell bestätigt. Stattdessen äh.
Weiß man halt von diesem einen Haus, wo auch ähm ja,
ein christlicher Pfarrer wohl ähm super Sprayer war und interessant ist es auch in Bayern. Es.
Jetzt die meisten Fälle oder die meisten neuen, die man sieht mit irgendwelchen,
entweder Kirchgängen zusammenhängen oder aus irgendeinem Evangelikalen Cluster oder in Passau gab's halt 'ne Cluster im Beschöflichen Originariat
so, also in der, die in der Kirchenhierarchie selbst so und äh ja, also.
Bei der Frage, wo stecken sich denn Leute an, wo kommt es zu,
super strading, haben wir im Moment nur zwei Anhaltspunkte, das eine ist,
Fleischverarbeitung äh offenbar also und äh das andere sind ja religiöse Praktiken äh oder Freelle, Zusammensein in religiösen Kontext. Vermutlich.
Gibt's auch ja.
Da noch andere Bereiche gut das mit den Heimsituationen oder wo viele Leute auf engem Raum leben.
Wie alt in Flüchtlingsunterkünften oder Heimen oder auch in Krankenhäusern. So, das war ja schon,
länger bekannt, das hat man, glaube ich, vor sechs Wochen schon, dass äh,
das damals, nachdem die erste Welle so ein bisschen eingedämmt war, ist es dort halt aufgeflackert und Frage ist, äh ja,
man das mit Maßnahmen da jetzt auch äh besser im Griff. Ich ich hoffe aber.
Wir werden halt sehen, so die nächsten, ja, ich sage mal, zwei, drei Wochen. Ähm sollten,
noch interessant.
Sein, vor allem, ob es uns gelingt, jetzt wieder die Zahlen wirklich zu drücken, ob äh weil.
Eine Sache natürlich rein mathematisch, wenn man jetzt plötzlich so ein riesen Cluster hat und die Zahlen hochgehen, wenn man dann in Erfolgewoche nicht ein neues
riesen Cluster oder vier neue Riesencluster findet, dann gehen natürlich die Zahlen,
zurück aufgrund dieses ein äh oder einiger weniger großer Cluster
Das ist aber natürlich dann schon erfreulich, weil äh natürlich man
stattdessen auch diese vier neuen äh Riesencluster hätte haben können. Zum Glück gab's dann eben weniger oder kaum äh neue Cluster in der in der letzten Woche.
Und insofern ähm ja auf jeden Fall eine Verschnaufpause im Moment.
Wobei.
Was man auch nicht oft genug wiederholen äh kann ist, dass man nach wie vor aufpassen muss. Also nach wie vor stecken sich eben in Berlin jeden Tag fünfzig Leute an, sodass es.
Schon was, das ist nichts, ja? Und wahrscheinlich äh sind's
dann mit Dunkelziffer mindestens das dreifache, vielleicht bis sechsfach ist das sind tatsächlich hundertfünfzig bis dreihundert Leute, von denen wir reden, die sich jeden Tag neu anstecken
insofern ja, Maske und alle anderen Schutzmaßnahmen, keine unnötigen Treffen,
insbesondere in Innenräumen, es zeigt weiter angesagt und so also jetzt.
So zu tun, was leider man an vielen Stellen sehen kann, so zu tun, als wenn Normalität.
Schon da wäre, dass.
Halt ich für gefährlich und Asien Normalität ist nicht da und äh ich hoffe aber jetzt, dass wir da schon vor dem Herbst noch irgendwann hinkommen.
Du solange es kein keine Fußballspiele mit gefühlten Stadien gibt, gibt's keine Normalität.
Ja.
Plastiker kann man das nicht vor Augen geführt bekommen.
Ja gut, also das werden wir abwarten müssen. Das ist alles irgendwie ganz gut nachvollziehbar, aber,
in gewisser Hinsicht hat glaube ich auch dieser Tönnies Fall äh schnell gezeigt so, ah okay
es kann auch was passieren, das geht dann irgendwie ganz schnell und dadurch, dass er dann zumindest mal für zwei Landkreise auch wieder die Regeln schnell angezogen wurden, ne? Und das.
Leute aus Gütersloh beschwert, dass er jetzt irgendwie mit Nummernschild aus Gütersloh irgendwo,
schlecht ankommen, ne? Und dann mussten sie ja dann auch noch ihre Reisen absagen. Das sind dann schon so die Botschaften zwischendurch
die sicherlich auch auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise wahrgenommen werden, ja? Zumindestens diese ganze Schreierei, aber an sich jetzt irgendwie auch nicht mehr so groß ist, war ja auch alles so länger nicht mehr durchzuhalten,
Mal schauen. Also jetzt ist Sommer, jetzt haben wir irgendwie viel Grund draußen zu sein und wenn man es nicht übertreibt
denke ich mal, wenn man das finden. Was ich jetzt noch ganz interessant fand war, die Ankündigung von Bayern jetzt auch Tests für alle, äh, einzuführen und die dann auch zu bezahlen und ähnlich soll's ja zumindest auch in Berlin,
so seien dann für Kitas und Schulen, interessanterweise ab Mitte Juli. Also, sozusagen in Ferien.
Mhm.
Kann man mal machen, ja, wieso jetzt, jetzt, jetzt äh testen wir halt auch alles, bloß keiner da. Nichts dafür. Na gut, also ich glaube, dass das scheint auch hier so ein.
So ein Trend zu sein, der sich jetzt abzeichnet, dass man jetzt einfach eingesehen hat und muss jetzt einfach ein breites Testing ermöglichen, um einfach schnell irgendwas abfangen zu können. Und ich denke, diese Debatte, die wird dann auch einfach, sobald die äh Tage wieder ein bisschen kühler werden
wird die einfach von alleine kommen. Also es ist ja nicht weg,
Zumal und da können wir ja einfach mal vielleicht jetzt wirklich mal wieder einen Blick in die weite Welt werfen.
Andere Länder ist einem ja wunderbar vormachen, wie man's nicht tun sollte. Ich weiß gar nicht wem man da äh als.
Erstens und am wichtigsten in Prarstellen sollte ja wahrscheinlich die USA. Weil ich glaub so die USA jetzt einfach.
Die hätte sozusagen alle Möglichkeiten gehabt, es im Griff zu kriegen und,
man sieht einfach, wo man hinkommt, wenn man so einen gespaltenen Nation ist,
Ja, das, das, dass man sich dann äh alles versaut. Also wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, die Infektionszahlen.
Sind mittlerweile wieder höher, also die pro Tag in Neuinfektionszahlen sind höher.
Als sie's vor ein paar Monaten zu ihrem höchsten Zeitpunkt waren.
Das heißt, man hat da jetzt so eine Kurve, die man schön abgeflacht hat und dann hat man so sich gesagt, so war was.
Ja und äh jetzt rausche es nach oben. Die Situation ist nicht ganz vergleichbar, weil.
All die ganzen, am Anfang betroffenen steht in New York und so, also die Metropolen aus Küste vor allem.
Die haben sie auch weiterhin im im Griffholz, zumindest ist es jetzt nicht mehr, so wie es zum schlimmsten Zeitpunkt war.
Auch nicht mit der Überlastung der Krankenhäuser. Aber jetzt rüttelt das halt solange es langsam in die Südstaaten ein, Florida, Texas, Arizona,
einfach auch so klassisches Republikanerland, wo es auch halt Gouverneure gab, die eben auch.
Sich da einfach von äh von diesem Trump-Trend haben äh inspirieren lassen. Keine Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, keine Maskenpflicht äh einzuführen, sei es mal nur in den.
Äh läden und so ein bisschen und das geht schon weg an den Tag gelegt haben, na ja und jetzt stehen sie da und haben wirklich krasse äh krasse Anstiegszahlen. Nicht nicht die höchsten der Welt.
Wenn man das mal auf die Bevölkerung umrechnet, da gibt's immer noch so ein paar einzelne Länder wie Katar, glaube ich, die sind so ganz weit vorne, ähm.
Also klar Brasilien ist äh Indien, haben auch steigende äh Zahlen et cetera, das liegt auch alles schon so ein bisschen so in so einem ähnlichen Bereich. Nur das sind halt auch alles Länder, bei denen das jetzt eigentlich erst so richtig losrollt.
Und die bisher noch gar nichts im Griff hatten. Die USA hätte es halt in den Griff kriegen können.
Ja
Also was halt auch schwierig ist bei der Interpretation, was denn da in den USA vor sich geht ist, weil das Land halt so riesengroß ist und,
eigentlich,
ist dann halt wie Europa zusammennehmen, wo man auch sagen kann, okay, in Italien ist es zuerst losgegangen und dann in anderen Ländern
eben
dann mit Verzögerung jeweils äh aufgeflackert und so ist es in den USA eben auch, dass einige Bundesstaaten quasi durch sind. Äh da sieht es dann ähnlich aus, äh wie
In Europa, bei den anderen äh das halt aufflackert, aber Fakt ist, die Situation sieht
ziemlich und schön aus. In den in den USA und ob jetzt die zweite Welle,
jetzt die ist auf jeden Fall da, wie weit die jetzt läuft oder wie weit die hochläuft, wird man jetzt sehen, das,
merkwürdige ist halt ähm, dass die Zahlen.
Komische Bewegungen machen, so muss man das äh sagen, das heißt, wenn der Anstieg zum Stehen kommt, weiß man nie so genau, was jetzt eigentlich der Grund dafür äh ist, aber,
man kann schon sagen.
Dass die USA als ganzes äh mit einem der besten oder teuersten Gesundheitssysteme der Welt nicht.
Gut gefahren sind bisher, so in New York ist das Gesundheitssystem ja überfordert gewesen, da hat man so lange nicht reagiert, bis,
es einfach zu spät war, so und ja, in anderen Ländern an den Bundesländern, die du schon aus aufgezählt hast im.
Süden hat man einfach viel zu früh äh wieder die Maßnahmen, die es dort ja auch gab,
äh dann zurückgefahren. So nach dem Motto, heuer äh die fahren halt alle Maßnahmen zurück überall, dann machen wir das jetzt auch so unabhängig jetzt von der EPD miologischen.
Lage und gesamt Situation. Und was man halt auch sagen kann, ist bei den Zahlen, dass die.
In den USA eher so hoch sind, dass sie mit in in vielen Gegenden, dass sie halt mit normalen Mitteln oder mit.
Trekking und mit isolieren und mit Cluster nachvollziehen, nicht so richtig in den Griff zu kriegen sind und bezeichnet es ja auch.
Auch die ganze Medienlandschaft in den USA ganz viele Shows vor allem werden ja von den Moderatoren von zu Hause aus produziert. Ich weiß nicht, ob äh dir das aufgefallen ist, äh.
Ja ja.
So, die sitzen dann halt zu Hause in ihrem Arbeitszimmer oder haben dann einen Ministudio äh eingerichtet und ja, ich habe noch nicht gesehen, dass irgendwo jetzt große.
Shows jetzt wieder im Studio gemacht werden. Das heißt, eigentlich hat man ja schon das Gefühl.
Das halbe Land ist nach wie vor im Lockdown, ja.
Ja ist es. Und ähm man fragt sich jetzt halt auch, angesichts der aktuellen Zahlen, wie sich das, das sind jetzt bis noch ändern soll.
Weil, meine, wenn jetzt die Zahlen schon so krass sind und vor allem, wie du ja schon angedeutet hast auch.
Viel verteilter sind, ne? Vorher war das so im Wesentlichen,
die schwierige Situation in New York New Jersey so in diesem Hotspot, wo natürlich viele Leute äh leben, ne? Befeuert einfach durch viele Reisende. Jetzt ist man in so einer Situation,
wo einfach die ganze USA als ansteckend wahrgenommen werden kann und auch wahrgenommen wird, ja? Also Amerikaner dürfen jetzt nicht mehr nach Europa reisen.
Auch glaube ich, eine äh interessante neue Realität, nicht, dass das jetzt die meisten tun würden, so, ne, aber so die die Sommerreise nach Paris, die ist dann halt mal dahin und das sind natürlich alles so Dinge, äh die sich ändern werden. Und.
Als hätten wir sonst keine Sorgen, stehen natürlich jetzt im November auch noch die Wahlen an und.
Da kann man schon auf komische Ideen kommen, ne? Wem nicht eigentlich vielleicht diese Situation irgendwo auch nochmal in die Hände spielt, wenn noch nicht mal eine normale Wahl abgefeiert werden kann, ne? Gibt's ja die entsprechende Diskussion, um.
Briefwahl, et cetera.
Will ich im Einzelnen, die jetzt gar nicht so bewerten, da ist ja auch noch ein bisschen was hin, auf jeden Fall sind die Zustimmungswerte für die Regierung jetzt nicht gerade besonders rosig und das wird natürlich eher noch dazu führen, dass sie noch mehr,
um sich schlagen und das finde noch krass werden und wie krass es schon geworden ist, haben wir ja gesehen, wenn man sich diese ganze Black Live Schmetter
Bewegung anschaut, die ja dann doch äh schon einige Erfolge erzielen konnte.
Und ähm was ich jetzt äh auch noch gehört habe, dass in vielen Staaten.
Gegenden, so die Leute jetzt aus ihren Wohnungen fliegen, weil sie ihre Miete nicht bezahlen,
es gab zwar auch, je nachdem Staaten oder Counties, die dann halt auch einen Moratorium auf äh ja, Eviction, also aus
ja rausklagen ähm beziehungsweise rauswerfen aus aus Wohnungen, dann eingeführt haben, aber erstens
haben sie kein Moratorium für Klagen eingeführt, das heißt, dass sie.
Teilweise die die Vermieter trotzdem einfach jetzt vor Gericht gegangen sind und eine Räumungsklage.
Erwirken, die zwar nicht vollstreckt werden kann, aber das ist dann halt nur ein Vollstreckungsaufschub, ja.
Und äh ja und das,
kommt halt jetzt gerade ins ins Rollen und das ist natürlich gerade vor dem Hintergrund voll Corona, also wenn einige auch gesagt, na ja, das Einzige, was schlimmer ist, äh als,
jetzt acht Wochen in deiner Bude hocken zu müssen äh ist äh in in Zeiten ist halt nicht zu wissen, wo du,
oben setzen kannst und geschützt bist. Also und das ist natürlich 'ne Sache.
Wenn das so weitergeht, sind da sicherlich auch noch weitere Unruhen äh zu erwarten.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass er also deutlich über die Problematik mit der Behandlung der schwarzen hinaus ist einfach auch nochmal sozusagen so grundsätzlich sozialen Unruhen äh kommt, weil das betrifft ja dann auch noch sehr viel mehr Leute als nur die schwarze Bevölkerung.
Ähm sind ja auch schon mehrfach erwähnt, hatten und das war ja auch ganz am Anfang, wenn du dich vielleicht erinnerst, als wir so erstmalig schon mal äh darüber gesprochen haben, wie denn das so sich äh bei UK und USA ähm
entwickeln würde, dann meintest du na ja, USA hat ja noch ganz gutes Gesundheitssystem. Ich meine so, na ja,
das hilft ein Gesundheitssystem, wenn alle aus ihrem Job fliegen und dann keine Krankenversicherung mehr haben. Und das ist jetzt eigentlich das, was wir jetzt auch sehen, ne. Also es ist einfach das war eigentlich von Anfang an so mein Gefühl, dass dass dieses, dass diese.
Trennung, diese Teilung in der Gesellschaft, sich einfach extrem unangenehm ähm ausspielen wird. Und das haben wir.
Dann auch gesehen. Ah, also ist einfach.
Ja und das halt mehr Leute krank zur Arbeit gehen, weil's keine Lohnfortzahlung.
Und sich dann ja auf der Arbeit untereinander anstecken oder auch noch das verbreiten. Also
alles suboptimal, wobei,
die glaube ich Situation ist ganz, ganz unterschiedlichen den verschiedenen Teilen der USA, was man auch auch sagen.
Immer wieder dazu sagen, dass dass man die eigentlich nicht über einen Kamm scheren kann.
Nee, da fehlen mir auch ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen die Ressourcen, also auch meine Lieblingsquelle in Data
erzählt mir jetzt mal viel über die World, aber das halt äh man zwei United States mit äh der Europäischen Union vergleichen kann in ihren Grafiken, das finde ich ja alles ganz nett, aber es gibt halt keine Aufschlüsselung nach diesen einzelnen Staaten.
Und gerade weil diese Staaten auch so unterschiedlich sind und das Land so groß ist
wäre das eigentlich mal ganz schön eine ähnliche Transparenz zu haben, auch auf Staaten eben nur zumal die ja jetzt auch schon dazu übergegangen sind, untereinander Quarantäne, Maßnahmen zu erfordern, ne? Also offiziell, wenn ihr jetzt von irgendeinem
Land nach New York fährst, dann äh hast du dich dazu Quarantinisieren, also da ist jetzt so New York und Texas im Prinzip so wie Deutschland und Italien,
das, so die sich äh äh voreinander abschotten und das ist natürlich auch ein ganz neues Gefühl. Ja, ich denke, das.
Glaube ich überhaupt sehr viel davon abhängen, was diese Wahl letzten Endes bringen wird, beziehungsweise wie die überhaupt laufen wird, weil das wird bestimmt total dreckig.
Also richtig, richtig schlimm.
Ja, nicht befürchte auch, dass das Schlimmste, also auch, dass es vielleicht sogar zu einer Verfassungskrise äh kommen könnte, wobei ich nicht drauf äh äh hoffe und ähm.
Ähm bezeichnet ist natürlich auch,
dass ja mittlerweile viele Republikaner beginnen, angeblich äh dem Präsidenten auch den Rücken zu kehren oder sehen, dass das jetzt ja.
Äh Karriere äh schädlich äh sein könnte oder sich negativ auf die Wiederwahl äh auswirken könnte und ähm ja, man wird sehen, also davon hängt sicherlich auch mit,
aber äh ja, insgesamt wirklich auch eine der.
Schlimmsten Reaktionen überhaupt.
Auf diese Krise, die man sich nur vorstellen kann, so wo die Führung, also zumindest.
Auf Bundesebene alles mögliche getan hat, um die Situation zu verschlimmern. So.
Aber das mit Erfolg.
Das mit Erfolg, ja ja, mit äh.
Ja, was natürlich auch sehr leidet ist hydamerika.
Daran kann man aber auch wieder sehr schön sehen, wie wertvoll das ist, doch eine Regierung zu haben, die äh noch nicht komplett durchgedreht ist. Also es ist positiv Beispiel ist ja
Uruguay, die irgendwie fast überhaupt keine Fälle haben, weil sie einfach extrem schnell reagiert haben und die Sache sofort ernst genommen haben und sofort alle Grenzen abgeriegelt haben und Mastenpflicht und das volle Programm. Und dementsprechend geht's ihnen gut. Alle anderen Länder
überhaupt nicht gut, ganz schlimm, ist natürlich in Brasilien
ähm auch da politischer Prinzip genauso vergleichbar, wie die Situation in USA, mit Bolsonaro, der irgendwie alles noch viel schlimmer macht,
aber ich glaube mittlerweile sogar gerichtlich verpflichtet wurde, eine Maske äh zu tragen, habe ich zumindest gelesen, aber noch kein Foto von ihm gesehen. Das alles wie nicht so schön.
Äh ja, Kolumbien äh Chile auch hart getroffen, Peru-Ecuador, also all diese Länder, also eigentlich alles außer äh sieht überhaupt nicht gut aus.
Ja, gut, da können wir jetzt noch viel Zahlen aufzählen, was ich interessant finde, ist das, wenn man jetzt diese Länder vergleicht, ne? Also so USA ähm äh Brasilien, Indien, das sind so gerade so die totalen Spitzenreiter, bei den Ländern jetzt die sagen wir mal eine größere.
Bevölkerung haben, ne? Also, wenn man genau hinschaut, sieht man, ja, Chile, Katar und solche Länder stehen da auch relativ weit oben, aber da schwankt es halt auch ein bisschen schneller, aber so von den größeren Ländern fällt halt einfach auf.
Lopandemy und Populismus.
Ganz schlechte Kombination. Also nicht, also wenn du so eine Regierung am Start hast, der es einfach schwer fällt, die Wahrheit zu sagen, dann ähm.
Dann läuft das einfach nicht gut, weil einfach dieses innere Vertrauen, was so in der Gesellschaft benötigt, dass solche Maßnahmen dann auch angemessen sind und dass dass man, dass man die Öffentlichkeit auch mit der Wahrheit konfrontieren kann,
Da ist es bei uns ja eigentlich noch relativ gut gelaufen, ne, aber man sieht halt auch, man hätte noch einiges äh äh besser fahren können. Also auch die Mastendiskussion finde ich jetzt bei uns ja auch am Anfang ganz schön verkackt worden. Hätten wir das von vornherein durchgezogen.
Ja
Wenn man noch sehr viel besser dran gewesen und hätten jetzt vielleicht schon auch wieder einen besseren Zustand, aber das ist natürlich alles immer viel hätte hätte äh könnte. Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist.
In dieser Liste der Länder, die es jetzt äh die sich gerade nicht so gut entwickeln, auch Schweden immer noch dabei ist. Das finde ich ja wirklich haarsträubend.
Du hast ja mal Zweifel an den Zahlen, ne.
Ja ja, ja. Die Zahlen sahen halt irgendwie sehr sehr seltsam äh aus und,
was wohl auch damit zu tun hatte, dass es wohl ganz seltsame Anweisungen gab auch wie da gezählt wird
und äh sowie tote gezählt werden oder
überhaupt erkrankte, dass das passte, irgendwie alles nicht zusammen und mittlerweile hat sich ja auch der Verantwortliche
Regierungsberater oder
Gesundheitschef, äh wie auch immer, äh öffentlich entschuldigt, äh dafür, dass es nicht gelungen ist, die Alten zu schützen, weil
wohl vor allen Dingen
ja, der Virus relativ unkontrolliert erhalt dort durch die Seniorenresidenzen und Altersheime und so durchgegangen ist und da er richtig richtig
schaden, angerichtet hat und.
So ursprünglich war wohl die These, äh man dachte, na ja in Schweden hat man halt so eine Alterssigregierte,
Gesellschaft, da kann man die altenden besser abschirmen als in Italien, wo mehrere Generationen zusammenleben, das hat man ein bisschen als Hoffnung
äh genommen, warum es sie nicht so wie in Italien kommen muss in Schweden, aber das ist halt komplett nach hinten,
losgegangen. Also da sagen, da hat Schweden einfach vor allen Dingen die ältere Bevölkerung komplett im Stich gelassen
äh die halt besonders betroffen. Aber es ja nicht heißt, dass nicht auch junge Leute äh Leute.
Beliebigen Alters, schwere Schäden davontragen oder sterben, äh aber so zahlenmäßig,
Ist es halt noch ziemlich schlimm und es sieht auch nicht so aus. Im Moment als wenn das so richtig zum,
Stillstand kommen würde, ne. Also gerade gut, die haben komische Lücken auch in den Zahlen und so, aber gerade gestern,
wohl wieder ein neuer absoluter Rekord an Neuinfektionen und,
Wenn man ein anderes Ding, ich hatte gerade mal zufällig auch den.
Blick auf Tschechien geworfen, dass ja ich das auch ziemlich gut bewältigt hatte, aber in Tschechien
äh scheinen jetzt auch die Zahlen wieder etwas angezogen äh zu haben.
Das stimmt.
Such. Also das ist mir jetzt auch noch unklar, wahrscheinlich gut hat man die Maßnahme jetzt.
Dort zurückgefahren, aber ja, das ist, also da sind jetzt gerade in der in der letzten Woche äh so, gab's da auch irgendwelche,
Ja, fast Rekordzahlen muss man, muss man sagen, das ist ja beunruhigend,
Musst du halt sehen. Äh ich habe da jetzt keine Informationen, aber werde mich mal schlau machen,
bis da auch Cluster sind oder ob's da allgemein aufflackert, könnte natürlich auch sein, dass dort jetzt nach der Grenzöffnung,
halt ganz viel aus anderen Ländern äh reingebracht wurde. Vor allem, ja, wie hat das, wie steht eigentlich Rumänien äh da, weißt du, irgendwas von Rumänien eigentlich.
Rumänien ähm in punkto Feller.
Ja und überhaupt äh mal gucken.
Rumänien ist auch.
Nicht so gut. Also Minion hat gerade ungefähr genauso viele Fälle, also jetzt relativ zur Bevölkerung.
Und vom Käses liegt Rumänien ungefähr da, wo.
Noch über Tschechien und auch noch über UK,
also auch Tschechien hat gerade sozusagen überholt an neun Cases,
Ja, also ums Markus konkretisieren, sechzehn Komma acht vier äh also jetzt pro Millionen, ne? Während wir bei Deutschland so bei fünf Komma acht liegen.
Hm. Ja, nicht schön. Ne.
Ja, dann können wir damit, glaube ich, den äh Weltenblick auch erstmal äh abschließen, kommen wir noch zu einer anderen beliebten Rubrik, dieses Formates.
Denn äh wir wollten ja eigentlich hier äh auch nochmal schauen, wie man das Ganze digital bekämpfen kann. Ähm.
Die Corona Warnapp jetzt ist ja irgendwie seit zwei Wochen irgendwie äh da, ne? Und.
Wir haben jetzt vierzehn Komma ein Millionen Downloads offiziell als verkündete Zahl bekommen.
Vom RKI. Das ist dann natürlich ganz RKI, auch die einzige Information, die man bekommt.
Wäre ja jetzt auch zu blöd gewesen, wenn man da etwas transparenter wäre so, ne, weil gibt natürlich eine ganze Menge Zahlen, die
uns noch mehr interessieren würden. Zunächst einmal war es ja so am Anfang, weil ging's ja extrem schnell weg, also die Anfangsinteresse war extrem hoch, man war sehr schnell bei zwölf Millionen. Dann hat sich das äh so langsam weiterentwickelt und es gab dann
Download-Zahlen so eine Größenordnung von zwei bis dreihunderttausend pro Tag. Jetzt äh gestern waren's halt nur hunderttausend, die noch dazu kamen, also die das Wachstum hat doch schon sehr abgenommen.
Mit meinen eingeschränkten, mathematischen Möglichkeiten, wenn ich da mal so schaue, könnte das bedeuten, dass wir so in zwei, drei Wochen, ja, vielleicht grade mal so bei sechzehn Millionen Downloads ähm angekommen sind, was,
meiner Meinung nach steigerungsfähig ist, ne? Sicherlich alles mehr als als ähm die Kritiker am Anfang so meinten.
Aber für einen Optimisten reicht das jetzt noch nicht so ganz aus.
Ja, ich hatte ja, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung hatte ich so gesagt, wahrscheinlich so zwanzig Millionen ist wahrscheinlich eher so
eine realistische.
Größenordnung, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, äh weil ja, am Anfang geht's natürlich immer ziemlich schnell und äh dann ja.
Ja, so hat offensichtlich jetzt nicht so viel gebracht, dass äh breit plakatiert wird und das äh Fußballspieler mit dem Corona Warnapp Logo äh an der Schulter durch die Gegend liefen
ist ja alles ganz nett, finde ich auch okay. Ähm keine Ahnung, schaut kein Fernsehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendwelche Spots geschaltet sind. Das fände ich ja auch nochmal ganz interessant
Ansonsten ist das so eher so ein klassisches,
Marketing, was da betrieben wird, was sicherlich noch steigerungsfähig ist und ich fänd's ja auch schon ganz gut, wenn das nochmal weiter thematisiert werden würde. Aber nehmen wir es jetzt erstmal so, wie es ist. Was sagt jetzt die Zahl? Ich habe mir mal so Bevölkerungszahlen geschnappt, dass mal so grob gegengerechnet
gegen die Bevölkerung ab fünfzehn Jahre. Das habe ich jetzt genommen, weil das eine Zahl ist, die ich.
Generieren konnte, ne. Und diese vierzehn Komma eins Millionen sind also knapp achtzehn Prozent.
Ähm der äh Bevölkerung ab fünfzehn Jahre in Deutschland.
Was habe ich gesagt? Achtzehn Prozent nicht stimmt überhaupt nicht. Neunzehn Komma fünf Prozent. Entschuldigung. Neunzehn Komma fünf Prozent. Also mal so grob.
Riecht das so ein bisschen so nach nach einem Fünftel der Erwachsenen und ausreichend Erwachsenen.
Person, so die so gemeinhin auch ein Smartphone ihr eigen nennen und damit äh aktiv unterwegs sind. Wenn wir viele sagen, ja, aber ich bin ja vierzehn und ich habe auch noch ein Smartphone. Gut, meint wegen die Zahlen.
Zerren sich jetzt nicht groß, wenn ich jetzt noch äh andere Altersgruppen noch mit rein nehme für so eine grobe Betrachtung, die es ja ohnehin ist, muss das jetzt erstmal reichen.
Ähm jetzt
gibt's viel Diskussion, ne? Was denn jetzt bitte der Grund ist. So, da kommen natürlich dann manche Leute mit ja, aber die Altgeräte, das haben wir ja hier auch, glaube ich, schon mal angesprochen
das ist so ein bisschen so eine müsige Diskussion, weil immer so getan wird, als wäre das jetzt irgendwie absichtlich und ein großer Fehler, das hätte man ja alles verhindern können. Nur das Ding ist,
der aller, aller, allergrößte Teil dieser sogenannten Altgeräte, die nicht unterstützt werden von dieser App haben auch die Technologie nicht.
Die verfügen einfach nicht über die es notwendige Bluetooth und äh andere äh Faktoren
Wenn überhaupt ist es ohnehin nur ein sehr geringer Anteil. Da hat natürlich dann jeder so ein bisschen seine Anito äh Evidenz, ja, meine Oma hat ja gar kein Telefon, die Tante, die hat halt nur ein iPhone vier, weil die will ja sowieso nur anrufen.
Und äh das nicht als Smartphone benutzt, sondern das lag halt noch so rum und deswegen kaufe ich mir jetzt nichts anderes,
Ja, mag sein. Das betrifft aber dann halt doch im Wesentlichen die Leute, die ohnehin jetzt nicht so die,
Hauptanteil der Mobilität in Deutschland ausmachen. Ja.
Wer ist viel unterwegs? Wer hat viele soziale Kontakte? Wer reist viel? Abgesehen jetzt mal von Familien, fahren in den Urlaub.
Hast du halt Leute, die arbeiten, die im Beruf sind, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer unterwegs sind, sonst gerne äh viel reisen.
Das betrifft natürlich die Älteren an der Stelle jetzt auch nicht so sehr. Und da dieses App Konzept ja auch grundsätzlich sagt,
Es soll halt Dritte schützen, ja, sind natürlich jetzt auch ältere mitgeschützt,
Die können bloß nicht selber mithelfen mitzuschützen, wenn sie denn eben nicht ein Telefon haben oder das nicht bei sich haben, et cetera äh PP. Also.
Ich glaube allein die Tatsache, dass permanent neue
Telefone verkauft werden und solche Abgreizen sicher dann zumindest ein zweiter und dritter Instanz auch nach hinten durchsetzen, ne? Leute kommen sie ein neues Telefon, das alte war ja noch nicht so alt, wird weiterverkauft und da wird dann wieder noch älteres äh weiterverkaufen
und irgendwann natürlich dann auch aus dem Markt gezogen, wird sich das dann von alleine lösen, dieses Problem.
Was allerdings ein deutlicheren Anteil haben konnte, dass die Zahlen noch nicht da sind, wo sie ähm sein sollten, ist die Tatsache, dass zumindest die iPhone Version von der Corona Warn-App nicht
in bestimmten Stores verfügbar ist. Bei Android weiß ich's jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz genau. Und da hatte ich so den Eindruck, da war das überall verfügbar. Aber beim iOS App Store
muss man ja explizit sagen, ja, das soll aber auch in dem Land, in dem Land, dem Land, in dem Land verfügbar sein. Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Rechtlicher Natur war die App nur in Deutschland verfügbar. Das hat sich mittlerweile geändert
Da gibt's wohl irgendwie so eine Rechtsabteilung beim RKI, die ja offizielle Herausgeber ist und die sich
Ich weiß nicht, welche Gesetze, die sich angeschaut haben, warum sie der Meinung sind, man könnte das jetzt äh wenn man im anderen ist so eingeladen angemeldet ist, warum man's dann nicht runterladen kann.
Ja, also der Meinung, man müsste da halt irgendwie Regelungen finden. Ich weiß nicht, was dir da einfällt. Das Einzige, was mir einfallen würde, ist halt so Datenschutz.
Und Privatsphäre, nur erstmal ist das ja bei dieser App eigentlich sowieso nicht das Thema.
Ja, also es gibt fast nix, was was weniger Haftung hat und dann würde ich auch meinen, was in einem EU-Land gilt, gilt auch in anderen EU-Ländern.
Hier offensichtlich nicht kurz noch jetzt.
Die App verfügbar außerhalb in Deutschland noch in Belgien, Frankreich, Polen, Bulgarien, Luxemburg, Rumänien.
Dänemark, Niederlande, Österreich und Tschechien. Mit anderen Worten.
Deutschland hat es so in etwa geschafft, die Länder um es selbst herum, abzudecken, mit der Ausnahme von der Schweiz.
Hat Bulgarien noch mit drin und Rumänien,
Also ein Schelm, wer Böses dabei denkt, aber das riecht für mich so nach äh Agrararbeitern irgendwie. Also sehr selektiv.
So und nicht so, ja, hier einmal Europa fettig. Also, es verstehe ich.
Tja, ja, vielleicht wollte man vermeiden, dass irgendwie plötzlich äh sich lauter Inder oder Chinesen äh die App runterladen und dann irgendwie,
die Zahlen verzerren oder so, keine Ahnung. Was anderes kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, weil eigentlich, na ja gut.
Frankreich vielleicht noch wegen Krypto, weil.
Frankreich gehört halt zu den Ländern, wenn du halt Krypto benutzt äh unter iOS, dann äh muss
du in den USA und in Frankreich, wenn du äh dort das Ganze freischaltest, musst du so einen Prozess durchlaufen, im Prinzip
äh muss so halt für die USA äh dann äh so bei
auf so einer Behördenwebsite dann sagen, was so mit der Krypto machst und warum die das nicht verboten ist und warum du keine Lizenz
äh dafür brauchst, da gibt's halt so Befreiungsregeln und das musst du dann halt einmal ausfüllen aus so einer auf einer Website, die so aussieht, wie ausm
letzten Jahrtausend und äh für die USA macht man das natürlich noch, aber Frankreich hat halt
so ähnliche Regeln, wo du dann nachweisen musst, dass du irgendwie
ähm einen OK im Prinzip von den französischen Behörden hast für deine Krypto und so
und äh ja da sagt man sich dann als App Entwickler dann nee durch den reifen hüpfe ich nicht und dann nimmt man halt Frankreich äh raus, sondern halt Krypto
äh äh macht, wenn man keine Lust zu äh hat, aber ansonsten, ja, außer vielleicht noch Vietnam und äh Nordvernahmen und.
Iran, wegen wiederum Exportverbot für bestimmte Technologien, äh aber ja, warum man's nicht für den Rest äh der Länder äh.
Freistellt, würde man gerne wissen, würde ich gerne wissen, aber ja.
Es ist einfach Unsinn. Also das kann mir keiner klar machen. Also da fehlt mir so ein bisschen der Wille oder die Bereitschaft, die Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Das ist das ist auch so so ein klassisches ja, nee, ich will ja nicht schuld sein, wenn wenn irgendwas falsch ist,
ich meine, wo ist die Türkei? Wie viele Leute leben in den in Deutschland, die vielleicht einfach im türkischen App Store drin sind?
Also es ist halt ja auch so, dass eine ganze Menge Leute.
Gar keine äh also fast nie oder ganz selten überhaupt Apps runterladen. Das ist dieses Ding. Ist halt.
Auch nur einen Teil der Leute, die meisten, ja, nehmen halt das, was drauf ist, auf dem Telefon, das reicht den völlig aus und ähm ja.
Haben da gar keinen Bedarf oder gar keine Lust, also äh insofern, dass das kann natürlich auch ein Faktor äh sein, dass manche Leute gar nicht wissen, wie man überhaupt eine App installiert, auf ihrem Telefon.
Das erklärt vielleicht, äh warum grundsätzlich, das weiß aber nur ein Datenpunkt, der irgendwann mal genannt wurde, dass sowohl die Hälfte iOS ist, obwohl wir ja in Deutschland eigentlich eher maximal fünfundzwanzig Prozent Marktanteil haben, also offensichtlich sieht es da
besser aus, ich vermute mal, dass dort eben dieses, ich Installiere mir Apps ähm sehr viel natürlicherer Prozess zu sein scheint.
Grundsätzlich muss man sich aber jetzt noch was anderes fragen, weil Downloads sind downloads und Downloads sagen erstmal überhaupt nichts aus. Ich habe auch aus Firmenkreisen gehört, dass einfach so die App ähm.
Dann einfach mal allen Mitarbeitern auf das Diensthandy Depleit wird. Das läuft dann so
dass äh die Firma, also jetzt auch hier wieder nur Eiweißperspektive für Android, kann ich das jetzt nicht so übersetzen, habe ich einfach nicht die Erfahrung, beziehungsweise in dem Zusammenhang jetzt auch keine konkreten Informationen bekommen. So, aber die haben da vierhundertachtzig Mitarbeiter, dann werden ähm,
dann geht's sozusagen der Systematmen dahin und er wirbt dann für diese Enterprise des spezielle Installationsregeln.
Vierhundertachtzig kostenlose Lizenzen für diese App. Ja, die sie dann quasi auf diese Telefone bringen,
das jetzt als eine App oder als vierhundertachtzig Apps gezählt wird. Kein nicht beantworten. Ich tippe mal eher auf vierhundertachtzig und.
Dann ist hier halt auch erstmal nur installiert worden. Es ist quasi ein automatischer Vorgang und noch nicht mal so ein bewusster Vorgang, der dann.
Von den Leuten auch noch abgeschlossen wird. Gut, da wird's dann Aussagen geben und die Leute, die Mitarbeiter werden ermutigt und was nicht alles, aber man kann sich sehr viele Szenarien vorstellen, wo diese App
einfach letzten Endes zwar auf dem Telefon landet, aber eben nicht wirklich
aktiv ist. War ja da eben noch ein paar Schritte durchgeführt werden mussten. Hier so Datenschutz, ja, ja, ja, weiter weiter weiter, willst du das Protokoll einschalten? Ja, will ich wirklich, zack, bumm und wirst noch mal ein paar Mitteilungen, dann können wir ja auch Bescheid sagen, ja, meint wegen. So und
diese zwei, drei Minuten mit oder ohne durchlesen, musst du dir halt dann auch mal gönnen. Und natürlich dann auch die Entscheidung gefällt haben, das zu tun.
Fragt sich, wie kann man jetzt messen, wie viele Telefone tatsächlich aktiv sind? Das viria eigentlich relativ einfach möglich, denn diese Telefone müssen ja einmal am Tag nach neuen Kies fragen,
Und eine einfachere C-Methode äh gibt es nicht, aber es gibt halt bisher dieses der Sport nicht, es gibt keinerlei Informationen dadrüber, wie viele aktiv laufende Installationen es gi,
Und das wäre eigentlich mal die Zahl, die veröffentlicht werden muss, weil ich mal kurz einen Appstore gucken und zwei Zahlen zusammenrechnen und dann auf Twitter ein hübsches Bildchen poste mit rumlinien.
Sorry, aber das ist es jetzt nicht, ne? Und an der Stelle finde ich, ist auch wieder AKI gefordert, technisch
ist es alles kein Problem, da muss halt nur die Telekom dafür sorgen, dass ihr CDN, was die ganzen Request macht, entsprechende Statistiken erzeugt, aber mal ehrlich.
Wenn sie das nicht hinkriegen, dann können sie den Markt auch gleich wieder sein lassen.
Ja. Gut, man weiß jetzt nicht, äh ob sie vielleicht,
das Absichtlich wegen Privatsphäre und Daten äh äh Schutz äh und so äh nicht machen, weil da müsste ja schon irgendwo
Wir müssten dann schon die Unique Zugriffe irgendwie gezählt werden und und so und dann sieht man halt die IP-Adressen und so, das will man halt auch nicht und.
Also die müssen ja eh explizit ignoriert werden, das kann man ja auch beim Zählen weiterhin ignorieren. Also nur weil du was zählst wird es ja nicht dadurch auf einmal weniger Datenschutzproblematiker.
Nee, aber ich muss, also zählen, funktioniert halt üblicherweise über Lokfalts schreiben und äh dann ja äh die.
Ja, normalerweise aber hier hast du eine App, die halt so getimt ist, dass sie auch nur alle vierundzwanzig Stunden fragt.
Also das ist also da da kann man zumindest belastbarere Zahlen erzeugen als mit irgendwelchen Downloads.
Ja, also eigentlich äh also die Traffic statistiken zumindest äh müssten
Dasein, alleine nur aus aus technischen Gründen, will man ja sehen, äh wie die Auslastung äh ist und so, also man könnte eigentlich anhand des des Traffics
das wäre auch wahrscheinlich die Privatfaire schonste Variante einfach zugucken, okay, wie viel wie viel
Gigabyte sind eigentlich heute insgesamt rausgegangen so und dann weiß man halt, wie viel da hatten drauf sind und dann teilt man das durch hat man, glaube ich, schon eine ganz gute Größe, also insofern hast du Recht, gibst da.
Eigentlich eine Möglichkeit, das zu ermitteln, muss halt jemand machen.
Genau und muss jemand den Mut haben auch zu sagen, okay, wir haben zwei das tolle Download-Zahlen äh bekannt gegeben, die schön klingen, aber tatsächlich ist halt die Zahl der tatsächlich laufenden Apps schwankend und anders.
Größer ist ja auf keinen Fall.
Ja ja, also es gibt Statistiken so, dass achtzig Prozent der Nutzer ähm nach zweiundsiebzig Stunden äh sagen, nach der Installation, die App nie eine App nie wieder benutzen,
das ist zwar jetzt muss jetzt nicht hier zutreffen, aber das ist zumindest der Durchschnitt so. Das äh sagen eigentlich,
ja, nur zwanzig Prozent der Apps äh auch nach drei Tagen äh nochmal äh wieder benutzt werden.
Gut, das ist ja hier kein Problem, weil die musste ja eh nicht benutzen.
Äh du musst dir nur einmal aktivieren und danach äh sollte sie ja ihr Ding selber tun. Ähm wenn die Leute das dann eher benutzen, gut, dann haben sie entweder größeres Interesse oder sie tun das halt um irgendwas auszuschalten.
Ja, also, das muss auf jeden Fall nachgeliefert werden. Das kann einfach nicht sein, dass man jetzt hier ähm der Meinung ist, man man könnte das unter den Tisch halten, obwohl diese Zahlen.
Absolut wichtig sind. Ich meine, das ist ja auch einfach für die Modellierung und für die Einschätzung, wie hilfreich das sein kann, ist das ja absolut erforderlich. Ich meine, ich.
Wenn ich mich jetzt wieder ans RKI, wenn ich das RKI wäre, dann wäre das doch meine erste Forderung. Leute, ich will wissen, wie viel uns das hier helfen kann.
So und downloadzahlen posten. Meintwegen, macht sich schön, aber hilft uns ja einfach kein Stück weiter. Um eine Einschätzung darüber abzugeben, ob uns, ob das sozusagen, ist es wichtig
brauchen müssen wir das ausbauen, müssen wir dafür mehr Werbung machen, ja? Äh springen uns die Leute ab, geht die Zahlen aus irgendwelchen Gründen runter.
Er sinkt vielleicht die Zahl, das will man doch wissen. Man kann sich doch nicht ausruhen und sagen, ja, wieso ist er, haben doch genug Downloads gehabt, so.
Also das das finde ich einfach extrem problematisch und man merkt einfach, dass das LKI auch an der Stelle, glaube ich, überhaupt gar keinen äh keine Erfahrung damit hat
und dann weiß nicht, auch diese Argumentation mit ist, es kann jetzt nicht in verschiedenen App Stores verfügbar sein. Das ist einfach dahingehend schon total albern, weil,
Bundesregierungs Apps gibt's ja auch überall hier so Nina und so Katastrophen waren Apps und so und.
Also das ist einfach Unsinn.
Ja, anderes äh Problem scheint nach wie vor diese Anbindung dieser Lapser war zu sein, also ich habe bisher noch keinen Bericht gesehen von jemanden, der einen Test gemacht hat und schon so einen QRC,
äh bekommen hat.
Stattdessen gab's zahlreiche Berichte, auch von Leuten, die so Einblick beim Lapp haben, die meinen, naja, also teilweise kann einfach diese Laborbetriebsoftware das noch gar nicht generieren und da wo man's probiert hätte,
hätte es auch unvollständige Informationen darüber gegeben, wie denn jetzt diese QR kurz wirklich erzeugt werden sollen
dann mangelt es halt teilweise an der Anbindung, dieser Laps, an den tatsächlichen Server von der Corona Warn-App
das ist für mich alles noch ein bisschen undurchsichtig, was da jetzt eigentlich gerade die Situation ist, aber ich glaube, man kann zusammenfassen.
Dit läuft alles noch nicht so, wie man das eigentlich haben will. Also davon ist man, glaube ich, da noch sehr weit entfernt. Da äh werden wir sicherlich noch ein, zwei Monate warten müssen, bis, dass ich da irgendwas tut. Und ich finde das halt einfach
ja sehr wichtig,
dass das auch an der Stelle äh mal ein bisschen Transparenz geschaffen wird, äh dass man einfach mal sagt, so sieht's aus, das ist noch das Problem,
ja, einfach mal ehrlich sein, das äh äh könnte helfen.
Tja. Ja ja, aber mit irgendwie Mut und Offenheit, das ist halt so ein Ding, ja, na ja.
Ist es, ne? Irgendjemand anderes war mutig und hat aber dann tatsächlich ähm,
interessanterweise mich auf Twitter angeschrieben. Ich dachte so, okay, jetzt geht's hier irgendwie richtig äh äh los und irgendjemand hat mich auf irgendwas hingewiesen, das macht dann so den Eindruck, als ob dann explizit sieht, die hier rausgepickt wurde.
Und zwar jemand.
Offenbar in Berlin, der ähm ja eine Meldung bekommen hat, dass er.
Ähm nein, der selber Meldung gemacht hat mit der App, also deren Test gemacht hat, positiv war und dann äh mit der App, also dann Hotline angerufen hat.
Und dort sich diese Teletanen hat geben lassen, die in der App eingegeben hat und sie da ähm weiß nicht ganz genau, wie lange es gedauert hat, aber auf jeden Fall das Handy seiner Frau.
Ja, was sich natürlich in seiner Nähe äh befunden hat in den letzten Tagen. Äh er hat dann eben tatsächlich so eine Warnung ausgesprochen. Also da hat man das erste Mal gesehen, dass dass das Modell grundsätzlich auch funktioniert.
Gut zu wissen.
Ja, genau, gut zu wissen
und äh irgendwo anders, da habe ich jetzt aber noch keine echte Quelle gefunden in Köln, angeblich äh habe sich wohl jetzt auch jemand äh daraufhin beim Gesundheitsamt gemeldet, ne? In dem Fall äh
weiß ich, dass das jetzt sozusagen nicht erforderlich war, weil die sozusagen eh als Haushalt schon beim Gesundheitsamt in dem Moment abgedeckt waren und die
haben es auch jetzt auf sich zukommen, sehen, weil da war schon klar, dass sie äh in der Nähe von infizierten Waren. Und das äh war sozusagen.
Absehbar, dass dass dieser Fall positiv sein wird. Aber funktioniert grundsätzlich, funktioniert und jetzt hängt's natürlich davon ab, wie sind die Zahlen? Und das ist natürlich so eine andere Sache, wo die Zahlen unklar sind.
Es gibt jetzt so ein paar äh Leute, die ja haben, so Trecker aufgebaut. Die sozusagen den so so Trecker äh äh Trecker. Wir trinken den äh Trecker.
Und tatsächlich ist es ja nun so,
dass man diese ganzen Schlüssel rausgibt, vermischt mit so Fake Schlüsseln, um einfach nochmal das Ganze zu verschleiern. Damit bläht man den Daten bestand nochmal um Faktor zehn auf.
Aber man.
Kann eben leichter irgendwas äh publizieren ohne gleich das Gefühl haben zu müssen, dass eben die ganzen Kies jetzt auch in ihrer Reihenfolge kombiniert werden können. Haben wir hier schon tausend Mal.
Diskutiert. Ich empfinde die Bedrohung davon.
Immer noch extrem gering, sodass ich das nicht unbedingt als notwendig äh angesehen äh hätte, aber das mögen andere Leute anders bewerten. Tatsächlich geht es jetzt raus.
Und was man halt jetzt auch sehen kann und daran kann man nämlich jetzt auch ganz gut nachrechnen, wie viele,
ähm Meldungen ist denn nun tatsächlich gegeben hat vor voraussichtlich es ist ja so, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich war positiv.
Dann kriegst diese Tele dann also ich krieg das positive Ergebnis, dann gehe ich zu der Hotline und sage, hier gibt Martan.
Gebt die ein und dann werden ja die Schlüssel, die meine App verwendet hat in den letzten vierzehn Tagen.
Um diese ganzen IDs zu erzeugen, die werden dann veröffentlicht. Aber diese Schlüssel.
Ähm also die einzelnen Tage haben einen unterschiedlichen Risikofaktor.
Dieses Transmissionsrisiko. Und das wird da so drauf gerechnet, soweit ich das sehe.
Die App fragt einen noch nicht nach so richtigen, diagnose Ergebnissen. Man würde ja jetzt meinen.
Dass das Erkrankungsdatum, wie bei der Meldung beim Gesundheitsamt, hier der entscheidende Faktor ist, ja.
Sondern man geht wohl davon aus, dass äh der Tag.
Ähm der Einreichung, so mehr oder weniger zwei Tage nach dem schlimmsten Tag liegt. Also, dass man sozusagen mehr oder weniger sofort mitbekommen hat, zum Symptom, Test.
Meldung. So. Wir wissen, das wird nicht immer so sein
Ne, also es gibt da Verzögerungen. Und ihr könnt mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man an der Stelle die App nochmal nachrüsten sollte, um das einfach Granulara zu machen
warum? Weil nämlich jetzt jeder einzelne Schlüssel der rausgeht mit so einem Transmissionsrisiko verbunden ist. Und das ist so eine Kurve. Das heißt, die Tage vor vorgestern vor vorgestern irgendwie so, wenn am höchsten bewertet, das ist dann dieser Risikofaktor acht
Ähm Tage danach, dann geht das halt irgendwie äh runter und in dieser Risikoverteilungskurve gibt's äh verschiedene Werte, aber nur einen Tag davon hat den Risikofaktor sechs.
Derzeit.
So ist es derzeit definiert. Das kann sich ändern, aber derzeit ist es so. Das heißt, wenn man sich jetzt die Schlüssel runterlädt, diese ganzen Kryptokies.
Von dem man ja nicht wissen soll, was sie eigentlich bedeuten, kann man denen tatsächlich anhand dieses Risikofaktors ganz gut ansehen, um,
wie viel Verläufe es sich hier handelt. Man weiß zwar nicht, was zu was gehört, aber man kann sich im Prinzip die Kies anschauen, nimmt sich nur die mit Risikofaktor sechs raus.
Teilt die durch zehn, weil alles wird.
Faktor zehn aufgefüllt und dann hat man in etwa die Zahl von Leuten, die jetzt tatsächlich diese App benutzt haben, um ihre Schlüssel zu veröffentlichen.
Und
diese Trecker, die es gibt, die berücksichtigen das und machen so ihre äh Einschätzung und äh da sieht das jetzt so aus, dass am, also vor einer Woche äh als dann so die ersten Meldungen rauskamen,
es irgendwie zehn Personen waren, dann elf, dann neunzehn, dann zwanzig, dann achtzehn, dann zehn dann dreizehn. Das ist jetzt so der Stand der Dinger.
Also, ungefähr so zehn bis zwanzig pro Tag.
Und ich sehe auch äh hier die nette äh Grafik so,
Wo das ins Verhältnis gesetzt wurde zu den äh gemeldeten Neuinfektionen,
da waren's halt gestern äh fünf Prozent der,
positiv getesteten äh haben ihren Diagnoseschlüssel.
Über die App geteilt. So und das lässt natürlich auch schon mal interessante Schlüsse.
Zu, also ähm also ich finde die fünf Prozent doch,
ganz äh gut, also ich hätte jetzt.
Erstmal auf weniger getippt, aber ähm ja, also ich finde die fünf Prozent jetzt erstmal nicht nicht schlecht. So.
Das heißt so, jeder zwanzigste, der tatsächlich jetzt einen Test einen positiven Test erhalten hat und sich gemeldet hat, hatte auch schon die App.
Oder war zu.
Die App und.
Benutzt sozusagen.
Und und war bereits lang andere zu warnen.
Ja und das ist, würde ich sagen schon mal, ja, ich ich finde, dass sich nichtikant. So, das ist äh ja.
Schon mal gar nicht schlecht, wenn man sagt, was, ungefähr sowieso nur zwanzig Prozent, beziehungsweise ähm,
Na ja, was bei fünfzehn, sechzehn Prozent, haben sich die App überhaupt nur runtergeladen und.
Wenn davon ein Drittel ungefähr ähm sagen bereit ist äh dann zu melden. Ja.
Finde ich gut.
Also könnte, könnte schlechter aussehen, muss man natürlich jetzt ein bisschen abwarten, das sind jetzt Zahlen, die sind jetzt eine Woche alt, die schwanken auch noch extrem und wir wissen ja, die Meldungen schwanken eh, man kann das jetzt nicht so eins zu eins korrigieren. Äh ich denke so in ein paar Wochen
wenn man dann eben auch äh schön hier die äh christliche Logistikfunktion da drüber legen kann und so sieben Tage,
Mittelwert bildeten, dann wird das etwas aussagekräftiger sein, dann wird dann man vielleicht auch so ein Trend sehen, ne? Tatsächlich ist das wirklich eine sehr interessante Korrelation.
Dass äh man einfach die gemeldeten Neuinfektionen hier mit den,
tatsächlich äh gemachten Meldungen macht. Ich finde das jetzt wieder ein bisschen schade. Jetzt sind wir wieder genau an demselben Punkt
dass jetzt hier irgendwelche Leute, also wir blicken jetzt hier gerade auf eins von zwei äh solchen Trecker äh Treckern, die einfach irgendjemand auf Gitarr veröffentlicht hat und einfach regelmäßig dann eben die öffentlichen Sachen ranholt.
Wäre es für diese CWA Server kein Problem, diese Zahlen auch einfach mal selber zu veröffentlichen. Die wissen ja, wie viele Leute es hat,
Sie wissen ja, wie viel Transaktionsnummern sie rausgegeben haben und wie viele Apps danach irgendwas geschickt haben. Das ist eine Information, die kann man einfach mal
in die Datenbank schreiben, das ist verletzt keinerlei Privatsphäre, das ist einfach eine wichtige Statistik, denn genauso wie wir die ganze Zeit vom RKI fordern, sie sollen mal genauere Zahlen und möglichst auch Maschinen lesbar raushauen, muss man eigentlich diese Forderung jetzt auch für die Chorona-Warn-App
machen. Das kann aber jetzt nicht sein, dass diese Infrastruktur öffentlich entwickelt ist und äh für die Öffentlichkeit da ist, aber sich dann eben nicht auch in ihrem Betrieb transparent macht.
Wir wollen das einfach wissen. Kann ja sein, dass die Zahlen unbefriedigend sind, dann ist das halt so. Aber dann kann man eben auch was dagegen tun, aber wenn wir jetzt einfach nur so tot sind, da ja, die Zivila, die ist ja da und so, dann ähm ist man dann wieder irgendwann mal wieder zu spät, ne? Und
denke auch so Optimierung wie Erkrankungszeiträume mit äh zu berücksichtigen und einfach mal auch mal bekannt zu geben, wenn sich diese Einschätzung dieser Risikoverteilung
ändert. All das, was ich halt jetzt hier tut, sollte einfach geblockt werden, sollte veröffentlicht werden. Es sollte schöne Grafiken geben, die jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen freiwilligen gemacht werden, wo
gegebenenfalls irgendwelche Fehler noch drin sind, weil das ja nur so Hochrechnungen auf Basis, dieses Schlüsselmaterial ist. Also das geht besser.
Absolut gebe ich dir, gebe ich dir recht.
Das äh ja das ist so optimal, aber ja, dazu müsste natürlich auch jemand.
Tun, sich drum kümmern, dass das das Tun und auch in der Lage sein, das zu tun und ähm ja, das äh scheint.
Offenbar noch nicht der Fall zu sein, beziehungsweise ja ah so, vielleicht hätte man.
Statt das Geld in der Werbekampagne äh zu stecken oder einen Teil des Geldes zumindest aus der Werbekampagne, wo ich nicht glaube, dass die.
Irgendwie groß,
Einfluss hat darauf, dass Leute sich die App installieren oder nicht. So, das wird nicht anders sein als bei, jetzt zum Beispiel politisch Herr Wärmung
äh so, wo man halt auch weiß, dass sagen Anzeigen, die eine Partei schaltet
äh bringen halt äh fast gar nichts, äh während.
Redaktionelle Berichte sind eigentlich das Ding, so wie wenn die Presse darüber berichtet, dann glauben die Leute das und dann beeinflusst es auch das Verhalten der Leute, aber sagen.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, so eine Plakataktion finde ich gut. Weil äh Plakate wirken und die das jetzt keine Überzeuger.
Ja, also das da da gibt's nicht dadrum, dich von irgendwas zu überzeugen, dann geht's nur darum, dich davon in Kenntnis zu setzen. Die App ist da.
Es gibt eine. So, ja. Hinweise zu Risiken und Nebenwirkungen, nehmen sie ihre äh Lokalzeitung. Und äh das das ist schon ganz sinnvoll, wenn man das jetzt so weggeschwiegen hätte, so nach dem Motto, wer wieso äh.
Wir haben noch vor zwei Wochen darüber getwittert, so kannst du nicht zu einer Verbreitung beitragen, so, ne?
Ich habe ja auch nicht gesagt, äh sagen, man hätte gar nicht äh werben müssen, wobei mir tatsächlich auch gar nicht so viel Wärmung aufgefallen ist. Äh äh für die Warenebe.
Also ich habe das so viel auf Plakaten gesehen vor Supermärkten und so. Das das war schon äh ganz gut platziert. Es war wie vorhin schon erwähnt, so beim Fußball äh äh haben sie so die Trikotwerbung ergänzt, et cetera, so eine Kleinigkeiten.
Vielleicht ist mir das jetzt auch noch mehr aufgefallen als anderen, das mag ja sein. Ähm ich bin ja selber eigentlich auch eher so ein so ein werbungsblinder Mensch, ich schaue mir sowas irgendwie nicht,
an und so mag es auch anderen Leuten gehen, aber es war in gewisser Hinsicht schon.
Präsent, aber das Ganze musste jetzt begleitet, wenn man heute, ich finde, das Interesse muss hochgehalten werden und das Interesse hältst du hoch, indem es für etwas gibt, worum er man berichten kann.
Und äh wenn du jetzt gar nichts mehr zu sagst, zu dem Erfolg außer wir hatten jetzt nochmal hunderttausend Downloads. Das ist nichts,
Aber wenn du sagst, wir messen jetzt mal ganz genau, wie sich das verhält und wir haben hier eine spannende Kurve und die schwingt und und die geht wieder hoch und wieder runter und was ist denn hier los? Und die Ferien haben sich so ausgewirkt und äh ja, Ferien
hier alle solche Dinge, das wollen wir genauso beobachten, wie die anderen Sachen auch und da ist halt einfach derzeit noch zu wenig und das muss sich ändern.
Vielleicht noch ein kurzer Blick auf äh Rest ist auch Rest in Europa.
Es gilt ja nach wie vor unsere Vorhersage, dass das dezentrale Modell gewinnen wird. Danach sieht's auch aus, es gibt neue,
äh Religis in der Hinsicht aus Dänemark, die äh Österreichische App, die es ja schon länger gab, ist jetzt auch entsprechend umgemodelt worden und ist ähm aufs dezentrale Modell umgestiegen
die Schweizer App, die ist Viscovit-App ist jetzt auch endlich draußen,
und es gibt weitere Ankündigungen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich jetzt alle mitbekommen habe, Finnland will Ende August komischerweise erst Ende August einsteigen und,
lustigerweise äh das Vereinigte Königreich.
Immer für ein Scherz gut ist und ja auch jetzt zuletzt.
Einsehen musste, dass ihre zentrale App nicht nur holst, umstritten ist, so Datenschutztechnisse halt auch überhaupt nicht angenommen wird und nur mit irgendwelchen Hacks auf iPhones zum Laufen gebracht werden konnte. Die haben das jetzt irgendwie eingestellt
Und angekündigt, dass sie jetzt auch auf das dezentrale Modell umsteigen wollen und ich habe äh auch gehört
dass sie wohl Interesse daran haben, die deutsche Lösung äh zu übernehmen. Und hast du dann diesen wunderschönen Dialog aus dem britischen Parlament auch mitbekommen.
Äh ja äh aber du musst das jetzt trotzdem erzählen.
Ich werd's einfach mal kurz ein äh spielen, das ist aus dem sogenannten PMQ, also die Fragen an den äh Primeminister, sprich äh der
Oppositionschef, der neue Chef von der Labour Party, hier ist Dama stellt halt Fragen an Boris Johnson, den Premierminister, der halt immer so,
Na ja, vor sich hin lügt und äh Sachen erzählt und jetzt auch von ihm vorgeworfen bekam, dass mit diesem ganzen Contectracing, da wurde es ja irgendwie überhaupt nicht äh vorankommen und dann meinte Boris Johnson, da ja Gott.
Gib doch irgendwie äh auch sonst niemanden, der das äh hinbekommt. Nennen das mir doch mal ein Land. Na ja, dann äh kommt halt dieser Dialog.
Wie aus der Pistole geschossen kam das. Ich hab's mir eine Kurzfassung, aber äh ist genauso gelaufen.
Ja, seitdem äh schauen sie sich wohl die Korona Warner genauer an, habe ich so den Eindruck, also das war ja auch so eine Vermutung von mir, dass jetzt vielleicht die Länder nicht alle auch nochmal zwanzig Millionen Euro in die Hand nehmen, um einfach dieselbe Scheiße zu entwickeln, sondern sich zumindest mal achtzehn Millionen davon sparen
und zwei Millionen in die Anpassung, an die lokales äh System investieren und dann äh äh läuft der Hase auch. Also es ist wirklich absurd, wie viel Kohle da verbraten wird.
Ja für schon bemerkenswert, dass dann gerade im im britischen Parlament äh dann ja in Deutschland äh sagen als positives Beispiel
in im Zusammenhang mit einer IT-Lösung äh genannt äh wird. Das ist schon äh außergewöhnlich.
Ja ähm.
Allerdings hoffe ich jetzt äh dass das jetzt nicht verkackt äh äh wird. Äh insbesondere.
Dieser zweite, wichtige Teil mit den Laboren äh und so, dass das halt mal bald in die Gänge kommt, wobei
Offensichtlich daher,
äh Leute in der Lage waren ihren Diagnoseschlüssel zu teilen, scheint ja wenigstens die Vollbackvariante mit dem ähm mit dem Call Center,
äh zu funktionieren, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie sonst auf fünf Prozent gekommen werden. Das muss man ja auch noch äh.
Na gut, ich meine zehn, zwanzig äh Fälle pro Tag, das das,
da braucht man jetzt kein besonders großes Call Center, um äh das zu machen und muss da nicht nur so eine vierundzwanzig Stunden Hotline kannst ja mit drei Leuten im Prinzip abfeiern.
Werden sie nicht haben, sie werden da sicherlich mehr haben, die vielleicht etwas unterbeschäftigt sind, aber diese Zahl wird sicher tendenziell noch,
steigern, ne? Also klar, wer rückläufige Fallzahlen heißt natürlich auch weniger solche Meldungen, aber höhere Download äh Slash Installationszahlen
äh mehr UN ist et cetera und äh vielleicht eben auch noch diese automatischen IDs auf den Test, das kann es irgendwie äh alles nochmal nach oben treiben
wird's auch angenehmer finden, wenn wir deutlich mehr als nur diese fünf Prozent sehen, die ähm hier gemeldet werden. Aber das wird sich dann wird sich dann zeigen.
Aber es gibt ja noch einen dritten Teil, der auch noch ausgebaut werden muss, dass diese internationale Verknüpfung. Dazu habe ich jetzt überhaupt nichts Neues gehört. Ich schätze mal, da wird einfach im Hintergrund weitergepokert und äh geguckt
mein Tipp nach wie vor ist, wir werden so ein EU,
sehen und ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn man,
sozusagen im Wesentlichen auf der deutschen Infrastruktur aufbaut und.
Die einfach dann diese zusätzliche Verteilung der Schlüssel äh macht. Es gibt wohl noch so ein bisschen Schattenboxen im Hintergrund.
Darüber, wie genau das im Protokoll dann äh stattfinden soll, also was die Apps machen, da hatte ich ja mal diese Vermutung geäußert, dass ähm die Apps,
war sie zu jedem Schlüssel sagen, dieses Telefon war an dem Tag in dem Land und dann wird das entsprechend weitergeleitet. Ähm,
kann sogar sein, dass es noch ein bisschen einfacher gestaltet wird, dass man einfach nur sagt, so ich war nicht in meinem Land und deswegen ist das so Schlüssel für alle,
Ja, also dass man einfach nur unterscheidet zwischen eigenes Land und anderes Land, dann äh ist das sozusagen nochmal etwas unproblematischer.
Ich denke mal, wir werden bald und ich hoffe das auch. Äh ein Update für die AP sehen, aber das dauert vielleicht noch etwas, keine Ahnung.
Eine Sache immer noch äh vergessen, Frankreich so.
Bei der Corona Virus App betrachtung. Und weißt du da irgendwas drüber.
Also bisher sind sie noch nicht eingeknickt. Ob die Zell zumindest nicht, aber die die Erfolge sind wohl sehr amager.
Ja, ja, also ähm nicht nur gehört habe, dass,
So in den ersten drei Wochen ist achtundsechzig Leute gab, die einen eine Warnung verschickt haben, weil die ihre positives Testresultat dort,
ähm ja hinterlegt haben in dem in dem System.
Was nicht so dolle ist, äh so, gut, das ist jetzt auch nicht gar nichts, aber ähm ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie viel downloades die haben. Ich weiß nur, dass ähm.
So in der ersten Woche, sie irgendwie knapp eine Million,
hatten, so an in Stalls. Das ist einzige, was ich.
Äh gehört habe und äh ja aber das ist halt schon äh doch.
Es ist halt in Frankreich eben auch nicht viel Vertrauen da. Ne? Also,
gar nicht mal so sehr konkret in die App sein, äh grundsätzlich ist ja auch, glaube ich, die Regierung Macron jetzt nicht so gut äh bewertet worden, wie das jetzt zum Beispiel in Deutschland der Fall war
Von daher mag das da auch mit reingespielt haben, dass die Leute dem eh nicht glauben, das kann ich nicht schwer einschätzen, wieder die Diskussion gelaufen ist, besonders Datenschutz. Where, sind sie ja jetzt äh nicht in Frankreich, zumindest nicht auffallend, ähm ne, mag es sein, dass ich das jetzt auch
langsam ändert, aber es hat natürlich nicht im Ansatz so sehr alles bestimmt wie, wie wir das bei uns der Fall gewesen ist.
Also ungefähr Faktor zehn, also Deutschland waren's irgendwie, glaube ich, zwölf Millionen in der ersten äh äh Woche oder so äh ja.
Ähm nee wir hatten.
Ja, doch genau, wir hatten in der ersten Woche hatten wir zwölf Millionen, richtig. Ähm schon am ersten Tag waren's irgendwie sechseinhalb Millionen. Damit ist man schon äh eingestiegen.
Ja, aber um eine Vergleichszahl zu haben sozusagen französische App, eine Million,
Die Deutsche zwölf Millionen in der ersten Woche und wir ja an der Kurve sehen, ist das bei den meisten Apps so
so nach einer Woche äh kommt da dann normalerweise nicht mehr so viel so schnell nach, ja?
Das heißt, die Franzosen werden jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwo Glück, keine Ahnung, vielleicht bei anderthalb Millionen sein oder so und damit kann man das wahrscheinlich als,
gescheitert äh ansehen und also auch noch eine interessante Zahl, die gerade von den vierundsechzig Warnungen, äh, die verschickt wurden, ähm, eine achtundsechzig Warnungen äh wurden äh.
Verschickt äh ein doch eins Komma neun Millionen Downloads hatten sie vor einer Woche. So.
Achtundsechzig äh haben irgendwie da zu dem Zeitpunkt Warnungen verschickt und sechzehn Leute wurden gewarnt äh bisher durch die A.
Also ähm ja.
Das klingt nicht so vertrauenswürdig, also also vor allem finde ich die, die waren, die die erste Zahl, die du gemacht hast, relativ hoch, also wenn wenn so wenig Leute, die Eppen runtergeladen haben, aber dann
sind das irgendwie genauso viele Meldungen, wie wir jetzt mit der gehabt haben. Bisschen merkwürdig.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, wir haben ja jetzt, sind jetzt schon bei über hundertsechzig oder so, dachte ich, ja, meine ich hätte ich irgendwie äh nee.
Nee, nee. Nee, nee, also, warte mal, hier ist nochmal, ob das hier bei dem Trick war, steht.
Dort auch bei dem Trekker gibt.
Zehn, elf, neunzehn, zwanzig, achtzehn, also, wie ist das? Gibt's das auch in Summe?
Da war ein ein Graf war da.
Asociat hundert, hundert. Na ja.
Ja, zum Schluss vielleicht ähm noch die Frage, wie das so mit der Pandemie sich an sich so verhält. Ich,
habe da noch so zwei Sachen gefunden, was irgendwie rumgehen hast, vielleicht auch gesehen, so eine Meldung auf BBC. Das ist irgendwie jetzt in äh China schon wieder so ein neuer
Schweinegrippe, äh Virus gefunden ist, der alle beunruhigt,
der wohl hohes Transplsionsrisiko hat, man ist ja mittlerweile so dran gewöhnt, dass zwanzig zwanzig noch weitere schlechte Nachrichten für uns ins Tore hat, ne
gab's ja jetzt auch noch diese radioaktive Wolke, die da in in Schweden gemessen wurde, dachte ich mir auch schon, sage ja, okay, jetzt am besten noch so ein nuklear
oben drauf, so wir haben ja sonst nix zu tun. Keine Ahnung was davon zu halten ist.
Vulkanausbruch könnten wir auch noch äh ja.
Hatten wir noch nicht, ne? Kein richtigen zumindest.
Ähm aber dann gab's noch eine interessante äh Studie und zwar aus Barcelona, die mich äh doppelt interessiert hat, deswegen auch.
Und das ist im Prinzip so eine weitere Veröffentlichung zu dem Thema, was wir hier schon mal hatten mit dem, mit der Abwasseruntersuchung.
Die haben also auch in Barcelona das Abwasser untersucht auf zwei Viren.
Und sind dabei wohl auch äh fündig geworden und ist ja so, dass wenn Leute halt das Virus hatten, dass das ja eine ganze Weile noch im Körper,
vorrätig ist, äh auch wenn es sozusagen nicht mehr ansteckend ist und sich eben vielleicht auch Gesundheitlich nicht mehr unmittelbar auf den Körper,
auswirkt, aber bis das dann auch alles mal wieder rausgeschwommen ist aus dem Körper vergeht halt ein bisschen Zeit und man weiß, dass es ja dann eben auch über Urinenstuhl äh auch ausgeschieden wird und dementsprechend irgendwann dann eben im Abwassersystem landet.
Und das interessante ist, dass sie es also nicht nur untersucht haben, wie es gerade so aussieht.
Sondern äh offenbar hatten sie zumindest bei einem von zwei Wasserwerken, die sie untersucht haben, auch noch alte Proben untersucht. Und zwar ist es so, dass diese Wasserwerke wohl standardmäßig.
Abwasserproben entnehmen und einfrieren. Und über einen längeren Zeitraum archivieren, um die Möglichkeit zu haben, bei Bedarf in die Vergangenheit zu schauen.
Wusste ich auch nicht und äh das haben sie dann da gemacht und tatsächlich haben sie einen Saßkopf zwei Virus gefunden.
Aus dem März zweitausendneunzehn.
Also in einer eingefrorenen Abwasserprobe dieses Wasserwerks vom März zweitausendneunzehn.
Und das ist in zweierlei Hinsicht bemerkenswert, weil erstens März
Ja, also kann sein, dass dieser Virus einfach schon viel länger äh da ist. Ja, gut, ist ja auch nicht so abwegig, aber eben auch schon den Weg nach Europa gefunden hat, das muss sich in dem Moment ja nicht gleich ausgewirkt haben,
Und äh das Datum ist auch deshalb interessant, also es war Ende März.
Die Probe oder so so äh neunzehnter März war das jetzt, glaube ich, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Und das deckt sich nämlich mit der.
Mit dem Mobile World Congress Barcelona. Die Veranstaltung, die der CBIT äh das Genick gebrochen hat, wo die ganze Welt äh einfliegt, insbesondere viele natürlich auch aus Asien, um da Telefone zu zeigen.
Die ja dann auch die erste Messe war, die abgesagt wurde, die erste internationale, als die Krise dann wirklich kam.
Ein Tag mich rumgelaufen, aber ich habe mich nicht anhauchen lassen.
Ja, interessant. Ja, das,
würde natürlich schon dann so ein bisschen die Geschichtsschreibung dieses Virus auch ein wenig auf den Kopf äh stellen, aber ja, ich halte es für möglich. Frage ist halt, wie belastbar sind, die.
Ergebnisse so und kann da Kontamination ausgeschlossen werden und so, deswegen, also wer halt interessant, wenn
ähnliche Untersuchungen vielleicht auch noch äh das bestätigen würden, dass man das Virus irgendwo,
äh ja in irgendwelchen anderen alten Proben eigentlich kann ich mir vorstellen, müsste es doch.
Proben äh äh geben, zumindest also auch in in Asien und so aus der Zeit, die eingefroren sind. Aber da ist man offensichtlich noch nicht fündig geworden. Hm.
Ja
Das wird noch spannend. Also zwölfter März zwanzig neunzehn. Ich habe gerade nochmal nachgeschaut. Ähm.
Das war auch nur diese eine Probe, ne? Also es war sozusagen nur am zwölften März neunzehn.
Ja und da war ich auch in Barcelona, einfach mal schon nah dran am.
Nahe dran.
Was hätte ich ihnen erwischt? Nun, denn Pavel, ich glaube, weiter kommen wir jetzt äh heute nicht mehr, das wird mal etwas kürzere Sendung. Ähm.
Ja
Mal schauen, wie wir jetzt hier unseren Tonus äh machen.
Denke mal, wir treten einfach mal zusammen, wenn's wirklich mal wieder was nennenswertes zu berichten gibt. Also jetzt diese.
Dieses äh wenn sich sozusagen das Infektionsgeschehen nicht nennenswert äh ändert und jetzt hier bei den Apps äh keine großen Änderungen sind, setzen wir vielleicht nochmal eine Woche aus. Das werden wir sehen.
Und dann können wir wieder zusammenkommen.
Wobei ich schon auch auf Twitter gehört habe, dass äh ja,
Tom hinten jetzt vor der Drosten-Podcasts äh und wie was zwei Monate pausiert oder so, was man denn sonst so hören.
Äh könnte und äh ja, da wurde dann von einigen Leuten empfohlen, dann doch uns zu hören, äh würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir da einen,
adäquater Ersatz für einen äh Drosten sind, aber der aber Informationsbedarf ist, glaube ich, nach wie vor äh da auch jetzt in der, in der Sommerpause, aber ich,
denke auch, also ich werde so, ja, weiter die Zahlen auf jeden Fall im im Blick behalten. Ähm ich hoffe,
ihr, dass sich der Trend nach.
Jetzt weiter fortsetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen, das sind doch Fecht, die Gesundheitsämter das in Griff kriegen oder irgendwie andere Wunder uns zur Hilfe.
Äh kommen und wir dann doch endlich wieder runterkommen. So im Moment.
Wie Eingangs schon gesagt,
Ja, äh haben, haben wir uns die letzten sechs Wochen eher seitwärts bewegt, beziehungsweise die letzten drei Wochen wieder eher aufwärts und ich finde es äh gerade beruhigender
äh wenn wir neue Minus äh Rekorde oder neue Minima äh mal äh hätten und wir dann auch die Sendung äh vielleicht dann ganz
einstellen, äh können, aber äh ja, jedes Mal, wir hatten schon mindestens drei oder viermal so die Hoffnung, ah ja, jetzt äh.
Noch zwei, drei Wochen, dann äh ja sind die wird's werden die Zahlen so uninteressant, dass äh wir dazu auch nix mehr sagen, äh müssen, aber das hat sich bisher noch nie,
bewahrheitet, aber ja, vielleicht.
Auf jeden Fall, falls ihr noch Anmerkungen habt, uns auf Dinge stoßen möchtet, dann tut es doch bitte gerne in den Kommentaren oder meint wegen auch auf Twitter
könnt nicht oder Pavel anschreiben oder auch einfach den ME Unterstrich UKW-Account, da wollte ich sowieso mal drauf hinweisen, dass dem gerne mal folgen dürft, wenn ihr
mitbekommen möchtet, wenn's Neuigkeiten gibt
wenn sowas diskret ist, äh gibt's meine DMs sind offen und außerdem könnt ihr auch mal eine Mail schreiben, also gibt's alle Möglichkeiten, bin für alle Hinweise ganz dankbar
und ja, ansonsten bleibt uns jetzt erstmal nur tschüss zu sagen, oder?
Tschüss und ja, passt auf euch auf.